heal minister palin
us can we with sit in gaz in terms of
medical facili how is the
sit all
year
are to cat are hit there is only n
hospitals out of 36 are working
partially meaning only the emergency and
some other some other services but  it's
not
working efficiently with all its
capacity especially in the south these
are located in the
sou
therefore the situation is totally
catastrophic okay can we talk about can
we then just struct it slightly one by
one in terms all the issues we want to
talk about  can we talk about the aid
that is coming in can you tell us what
aid has come in for what type of
inj may know that there is no medic
inside gaza no medical supplies only
those which through check and therefore
those who are entering they are  used
immediately and they are emergency
emergency care medicines and medical
supplies there are not specialized
medicines example we have in
gaz who are cancer patients are not tre
because
number if that is the scenario means that
only really accident emergency treatment
can be given the other issue  is trying
to get people to the medical facilities
that are operational how difficult is it
with so
medical
yes this another
is
of until now and many of them
either
dis if woman has toy her family and
number two get killed because as they
have 300  acc
med
paric
also qu of
med medical sta whose kally physics are
very special and they are almost un gas
we of our coles
are for ex ofy
emergency department he was killed the
head of the internal medicine he was
killed therefore
these these  medical doctors with a good
capacity they are not existing in gaza
now other issue
is the ambulances and the ambulance you
know
that ambulance have been destroyed
because they
were immediately and directly
amb as the minister for health for
palese you will of course have access to
conversations you can
have conversations are you having with
the who at le the un to try and get more a
into gaza at this
moment actually with who we have
been
together we communicate with them all the
time and inina them even the national
representative of palan here  has been to gaz
for almost two weeks and he visited all
the hospit
was
immed and aali in a very
good other with other diplomats also we
pass them all the needs in gaz and
prepared in gaza and they s us and we
them we are  sending them to the diplomat
and ag to
ag to the agen that are working for
emergency emergency medical care
therefore it is distributed all over we
have our website to and we have our
daily report in arabic and english where
we are putting all what's happening and
what's the need for the gaza for
gazp it's good to get clarification exa
sit as on the ground
the heal minister
than you
forin thank you thank you